on n'avait pas vu ça auparavant et c'est
une découverte des médecins français
effectivement ils ont décrit chez des
sujets jeunes une perte totale de
l'odorat avoir une perte totale du goût
ces personnes sont testées positives
donc il ya bien une relation entre ces
symptômes assez rare finalement et la
présence du virus
ce sont souvent des symptômes bénins
donc les gens ne faisaient pas forcément
attention à ces symptômes ne savais pas
qu'ils étaient contagieux donc c'est une
avancée importante
les nos collègues chinois n'avait pas
noté ces anomalies par contre d'autres
collègues anglo-saxons et canadiens nous
la signale donc les français ont été les
premiers à à signaler cette
particularité de même que comme vous le
savez nous avons décrit des formes là
aussi atypique chez les sujets très âgés
qui ont moins de symptômes respiratoires
et plus de symptômes digestifs
donc on en apprend chaque jour sur cette
maladie qui est une maladie nouvelle qui
atteint aussi de nouveaux territoires
nous avons probablement des
caractéristiques individuelles
différentes
ce qu'on appelle le génotype nous avons
des capacités d'aidé de susceptibilité
génétique et des réponses une éthique
différentes à différentes infections et
donc le virus progressant de pays en
pays on observe potentiellement cd des
tableaux cliniques différents